I got more good news that's the focus of
tonight's
Angle now there was a very important
memorial service today in Washington for
the pretend border Bill complete with a
eulogy that tried to explain put into
context the law been very clear with me
they have political differences with the
bill they say it's the wrong time to
solve the problem or let the
presidential election solve this problem
there are other
folks that read the Facebook posts in
the Twitter
post and saw different facts that they
thought might be
true but I personally told them over and
over again they're
false and it's been hard to
overcome it is a loss it's sad that he's
still using the same lines that didn't
work when he was trying to sell the
stinker of a bill but he wasn't the only
one imputing the intelligence of his
fellow colleagues who helped bury this
bill
While others had decided that border
security is just a talking point for the
election I can promise you this as
someone who was born and raised near the
border in Arizona this is not a talking
point for me this is our daily lives and
I hear from our ranchers I hear from our
police officers I hear from our Farmers
every day yes and I hear that those
arizonans know and have known for years
that it is indeed Kristen a crisis and I
bet if asked none of them would have
supported legislation that every year
allowed in millions of migrants and
foreign workers they would want an
emergency halt of all Asylum claims
because of scenes like this last month
the numbers are startling and they are
not slowing down take a look at what we
saw out here in lukeville Arizona this
morning another Mass illegal Crossing
through a breach in the border wall we
saw hundreds of adults from all around
the world Crossing illegally we actually
had two guys from Afghan
amongst this group which crossed here
illegally what could go wrong but the
bill of course would not have stopped
any of that contrary to what Langford
and Cinema were trying to say and if
cinema by the way was so sure that this
bill was a winner why didn't she just
demand that McConnell and Schumer delay
things maybe a few weeks then hold a few
Town Halls to whip up public support and
why didn't Langford insist on at least a
full week of debate on this bill why
didn't they both iously oppose
leadership's cramdown maneuver of
releasing the Bill's Tech Sunday night
and then rushing to a cloer vote today
of course it was going to fail we tried
to warn them Americans are not stupid
even if they think we are we beat the
powerful Chamber of Commerce we beat the
corporate media we beat the pro amnesty
crowd and of course the old
establishment not bad and if they try to
resurrect this corpse we're going to
beat them again also this this episode
demonstrated that the dinosaur media is
losing power and influence that's a very
good thing corporate sensors could not
prevent the truth about this legislation
from coming out obviously you've been
watching the angle as we meticulously
laid out the parade of horribles that
the senate had embedded in this bill and
then the education continued on Elon
musk's X where brilliant Senators posted
page numbers and entire sections of the
offending text
it was devastating thank God Elon Musk
can weather the advertiser boycotts and
thank God he doesn't mind being hated by
all the right people now in times of War
disinformation spreads like wildfire and
Tech Mogul Elon Musk is often criticized
for Fanning those Flames several
companies have pulled their ads from his
platform X otherwise Twitter after he
personally endorsed an anti-semitic
post that was a textbook smear to to
wound him financially and get him to
give up just as they're doing to Donald
Trump come on that all play nice with
musk if he simply started censoring
conservatives and let us not forget
tonight the good news about the
presidential race just as Jim Langford
ignored my advice to avoid being the
Fall Guy for that border Bill Nikki
Haley ignored my advice to drop out
after Iowa they might not believe me but
I was actually trying to help them
nevertheless as we saw in yesterday's
Nevada caucuses Nikki Haley's
stubbornness is the gop's
gain NBC News projects that Nikki Haley
has lost to the option that reads none
of these candidates former president
Trump did not appear on the ballot Haley
face some long shot Challengers and the
none of these candidates Choice there
you can see at the
bottom now stew on that for a minute
even with her massive campaign War chest
she couldn't beat none of the
above embarrassing now I'm going to say
it again every day that she's staying in
the race she's hurting her chance to
have any influence in the future maybe
that's what she wants and follow on good
news comes from a poll about minority
voters and their growing support for
Donald Trump according to Gallup
democrat's advantage over the GOP among
Black and Hispanic voters has shrunk by
nearly 20 points over the past three
years who do you think is better for the
country Trump or Biden Trump trump Trump
trump I say Trump why you say that he's
a businessman he's going to think
business and Biden is a racist no Wars
great policies best years in the stock
market Biden ain't do we G get rid of
his
sleep wow well the old Democrat
Coalition is slowly starting to split
apart and it is about time and with
Trump leaning toward what we've been
recommending for years a republican 50
state strategy for victory then things
could really get interesting it's about
time those broken New England states
come on they got to be in play again no
City and no State should be left
behind so don't let the Democrat media
machine not for one second have you
believed that just because the house
came up short and impeaching my orcus
that we're not on a winning role here
because we are the country is waking up
they're demanding real change and
they're looking away from Washington and
toward the guy who had us going in the
right direction just four years ago and
that's the very happy angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else